deux créateurs de vêtements à la
boutique scola eric fontanini et camille
andrieu sont les fondateurs d'habiles
une marque créée en octobre 2018
des vestes des salopettes ou des
tabliers avec des mains en activité
imprimer leurs particularités la
fabrication de pièces indémodables n'est
qu'en fait la veste à peut supporter des
deux côtés donc ça c'est un argument de
vente que vous pouvez aussi expliquer ce
nom vous confier notre projet et que la
vente à la fin c'est l'essentiel non on
s'est créé mais vous vous allez savoir
vendre et nous sans vous on sera pas
faire donc c'est ça aussi qu'il faut que
vous disiez avec habile c'est que notre
projet il va exister à travers vous et
c'est ça qui est important et c'est pour
ça qu'on est là et c'est pour ça qu'on
est heureux de participer au projet
scola ces vêtements seront à la
disponibilité des vingt stagiaires de la
boutique éphémère objectif pour revendre
le plus de pièces possibles
pourquoi commerce parce que j'aime
beaucoup le contact clientèle tous les
jours bas on a on a un nouveau challenge
et c'est ça qui est vraiment excellent
je pense que cela m'a apporté beaucoup
plus de connaissances les techniques de
vente comment conseiller les clients
comment aller plus loin dans la vente
litho une nouvelle expérience qu'on
renouvelle toujours avec les mêmes
objectifs développer le l'emploi local
et être vecteur de dynamisme économique
et de lien social
ces vingt jeunes âgés de 18 à 30 ans et
originaire de saint quentin en yvelines
vont être formés pendant deux mois au
métier de vendeur 24 heures de théorie
et 11 heures d'immersion dans la
boutique par semaine c'est aussi
l'accompagnement dans leur projet
professionnel et le développement du
savoir est et de la confiance en soi
ce jour là ça se passe avec aurélien
duarte champion de kick boxing et de
boxe thaï répète insiste quotidiennement
encre ton action dans la chair le
message c'est que chacun est responsable
de ce qui lui arrive et qu'on a un
pouvoir sur notre vie à la fin de la
carrière j'ai décidé de m'intéresser au
fonctionnement humain
neurosciences et j'ai pu mettre des mots
enfin sur comment je m'étais
transformant champions pour mieux
partager aux autres
aujourd'hui plus de 75% des apprenants
de la boutique scola éditions 2018 ont
connu un retour à l'emploi après cette
formation